HAS ATLANTA BACK WITHIN 13.
KORKMAZ IS BACK ON THE FLOOR FOR
PHILADELPHIA.
>> Hubie: IT'S NEVER OVER.
IT'S NEVER OVER.
>> Dave: 13-4 RUN OVER THE LAST
FOUR MINUTES BY THE HAWKS.
HOW WILL PHILLY RESPOND?
THEY GO TO EMBIID.
THEY'RE GOING TO CALL A FOUL ON
ATLANTA.
MAYBE NATE McMILLAN WILL
CHALLENGE THIS.
TECHNICAL FOUL CALLED ON TRAE
YOUNG.
THEY STILL MIGHT DECIDE TO
REVIEW THIS.
BUT OBVIOUSLY THE TECHNICAL WILL
STAND NO MATTER WHAT ON TRAE
YOUNG.
AND EMBIID WILL SHOOT THE FREE
THROW.
>> Hubie: THIS IS JUST BECAUSE
WE'RE SO HIGH UP, IT'S DIFFICULT
TO SEE.
ALL YOU KNOW IS THAT EMBIID
MAKES THE MOVE, AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN FALLS FORWARD.
NOW, IS THERE A TRIP?
WHAT DID THEY C